[Applause]
less than 48 hours after accusing his
opponents and protesters of attempting a
coup d'etat against him Bolivian
President Evo Morales conceded that he
could not continue declaring himself the
winner of last month's strongly disputed
presidential elections in a major
about-face Morales said there would be
fresh elections overseen by a new
electoral board we will have a new
national election that will allow the
Bolivian people to democratically elect
its new representatives brothers and
sisters in the media and the people of
Bolivia after making this decision I
want to call on everybody to reduce the
tension we all have a duty to pacify
Bolivia I'm calling for respect among
families respect for property and
respect for authority and for all social
groups the announcement came shortly
after the Organization of American
States announced preliminary results of
an electoral audit that left a little
room for doubt it indicated that
signatures had been falsified documents
tampered with and that it was not
possible to certify that Morales had won
in a first round as he'd claimed it also
called for an in-depth investigation to
determine responsibilities for
irregularities that are tantamount to
fraud but the opposition says new
elections are not enough the main
culprits of this fraud has led to
several deaths and hundreds of wounded
our President Evo Morales and Vice
President Alvaro Garcia Linares who must
be barred from being candidates in a new
election Morales had originally offered
only to hold a second round if the OAS
audit did not go his way
something the opposition said was
unacceptable the tipping point for
reversing his decision may have been an
indication that the army would no longer
support him if he did not hold new
elections
the new poll date and the composition of
a new electoral board are still to be
determined while much of the opposition
calls for more Alice's resignation
arguing he has not fit to govern after
overseeing what they call a massive
fraud you see a human al Jazeera
Santiago